[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today quantum electrodynamics
when two electrons get close they repel
each other
this explains why we don't fall through
a chair when we sit down
why we can exert a force on an object
and why the air exerts friction on a
feather
apart from gravity and radioactivity at
the nuclear scale
almost all phenomena in the universe can
be explained by how electrons behave
at first one would be tempted to
describe this repulsion by a force
the electromagnetic force but electrons
are not
small marbles that would obey classical
mechanics
they are quantum objects particles
and to describe their interactions it is
necessary to reconcile electromagnetism
with quantum physics to this end
in the middle of the 20th century the
most precise model
ever created in the history of physics
was developed
an elegant model which allows the use of
simple diagrams to calculate with
astounding precision
the most fundamental phenomena of
physics
quantum electrodynamics
quantum electrodynamics is an example of
a quantum field theory
we consider our universe as a sort of
box
space time which contains two fields
fluids made up of mathematical objects
the electron field and the
electromagnetic field
[Music]
within these fields move about small
packets of energy that can appear or
disappear
called particles
electrons for example are disturbances
that propagate like
waves inside the electron field
[Music]
the electromagnetic field also contains
disturbances
quanta of energy which can appear or
disappear
photons
the field of electrons and that of
photons are of a different nature
the mathematical objects from which they
are made up are not of the same type
the electron field in particular is made
up of spinners
rather abstract objects that are
described by complex numbers
to simplify we can imagine a complex
number as having a size
as well as a color its phase
when an electron propagates in the field
the phase of complex numbers
rotates over time this is called
the electric charge electrons have an
electric
charge which transcribes the fact that
their phase
turns as they move towards the future
[Music]
apart from electrons this same field can
also contain disturbances
whose phases turn in the other direction
in a way we could say that this is an
electron but which is moving
in the opposite direction towards the
past
[Music]
from our point of view the phase of this
particle seems to turn in the opposite
direction
we perceive an opposite electric charge
this is called an anti-electron a
positron
on the other hand the photon field is
formed of vectors
which are expressed with real numbers
they are just ordinary numbers which
have no phase
so photons have no electric charge
to understand how electrons interact
imagine that we place two of them
at the start of our quantum field
in order to schematically represent the
content of the universe
it is convenient to use lines to
symbolize the movement of particles
align with an arrow towards the future
to symbolize an electron
with an arrow towards the past in the
other direction
to symbolize a positron and a wavy line
to symbolize a photon
to describe how particles evolve quantum
electrodynamics allows our two fields to
interact
using interaction vertices
an interaction vertex involves a photon
and two particles of the electron type
these can be electrons or positrons
depending on their orientation with
respect to time
such a vertex can symbolize an electron
which emits a photon
an electron which absorbs a photon
a positron which emits a photon or
absorbs a photon
or even an electron and a positron which
annihilates
into a photon or a photon which converts
into an electron positron pair
all these interactions are allowed
provided that for each vertex
the overall momentum of the particles in
space
and time before and after the
interaction
remains the same the electric charge
must also be conserved
each interaction necessarily has an
arrow that enters
and another that leaves the vertex
by allowing our two electrons to
interact with these kinds of vertices
we can then imagine a whole variety of
different scenarios
in the simplest scenario the two
electrons continue in a straight line
in another more interesting scenario the
two electrons exchange a photon
which acts as a messenger carrying part
of the momentum of the first electron
to the second electron
it is important to note that particles
behave like waves
they can be exchanged along one
direction even though they carry a
momentum which is oriented differently
that way in some scenarios the exchange
will bring the two electrons closer
and in other scenarios the exchange will
push them apart
[Music]
we can then imagine more complex
scenarios which involve
many points of interaction electrons can
exchange
several photons at different places
and at different times sometimes
a photon converts into an electron
positron pair
which annihilates to form a photon again
we
call this a loop an electron can also
emit
and then reabsorb a photon
as long as the overall momentum and
electric charge are preserved
all imaginable scenarios an infinity of
more or less complex possibilities
can occur
and if we stop the evolution of the
field after a certain time
to look at the outcome of each scenario
we sometimes find
our two electrons and sometimes more
particles
with some having appeared between the
initial and final instance
each of these scenarios which start from
an initial situation
and reach a final situation is called a
refinement diagram
feynman diagrams transcribe the
different possible evolutions of our
quantum fields
from a given initial situation
apart from the initial and final
particles which are real particles that
can be detected
the particles that act as messengers
within these diagrams
are said to be virtual these are
particles that cannot be detected
and they can exhibit some rather strange
properties
they only serve as intermediaries to
describe how our two electrons
interact at a distance
mathematically each scenario each
feynman diagram
corresponds to a very rigorous equation
and virtual particles are only a way of
interpreting intuitively
certain parts of the equations
[Music]
that said although they are only
intermediaries resulting from our
mathematical model
it is essential to consider these
virtual particles
because they account for the
interactions of the fields
and therefore how electrons behave
let's summarize what we have so far we
describe
a space-time which contains two fields
that have electrons and that of photons
from an initial situation with two
electrons
we are interested in all possible
evolutions
allowing interactions that link a photon
to two particles of the electron type
[Music]
from this we can create a catalogue a
list of
all the possible diagrams there are
infinitely many
some are simple contain few interactions
and others are more complex involving
many interactions
but this doesn't help us too much if we
wish to predict
the actual behavior of electrons we'd
like to know which of these scenarios
actually occurs if we carried out the
experiment
is it this scenario or this other
scenario that would occur
the answer to this question is subtle
and may seem counter-intuitive
but it is precisely what makes quantum
theory so
powerful
our universe does not follow just one of
these scenarios
it evolves at the same time according to
all possible scenarios
in a way starting from a given initial
situation
all possibilities occur at the same time
in parallel as a superposition of
every imaginable scenario
to describe the behavior of electrons it
is necessary to take into account all
finement diagrams
in quantum electrodynamics each diagram
corresponds to an equation
which allows us to calculate a number
for each scenario
and amplitude we can imagine the
diagrams as
layers and their amplitude as a sort of
opacity that sometimes adds up
constructively
and other times destructively
the many different scenarios have
different amplitudes
but for the sake of calculations we can
usually neglect
the more complex scenarios considering
only
the first few simplest diagrams and
still get
reasonably accurate results
it is by performing the sum of all these
scenarios with their different
amplitudes
as if we superimposed more or less
opaque layers
that we obtain the real evolution of the
physical system
when we carry out the experiment in the
real world if we throw two electrons and
observe them a little later
the amplitude of each diagram allow us
to calculate the overall probability
that we observe a specific
outcome as the output of our experiment
and in particular the most likely
outcome is that we observe our two
electrons with slightly different
momentum
they repelled each other
in a way feynman diagrams are not so
much descriptions of real phenomena
but rather very powerful tools that
allow us to calculate the probability of
observing
such or such an outcome
we have a greater chance of finding our
two electrons with outward momentum
the most likely outcome is that they
repelled each other
thanks to the exchange of virtual
particles
at our scale we have the impression that
the two electrons undergo a continuous
force
while fundamentally this force is only
the probabilistic
synthesis of all possible interactions
in which the electrons exchange motion
through virtual particles
[Music]
to conclude quantum electrodynamics is a
complex theory
but it allows us to predict in an
astounding way how electrons
positrons and photons interact
by synthesizing all possible scenarios
with their different amplitudes
this theory explains and predicts at the
fundamental scale
all the laws of optics the behavior of
light when it interacts with a material
maxwell's equations which govern
electric and magnetic fields
and interactions between electrons from
which at our scale
almost all forces arise
historically this model was the first
great success
of quantum field theory by describing
matter as quantum fields
interactions as virtual particles and
proposing a very elegant calculation
method
based on diagrams and amplitudes quantum
electrodynamics has in particular
allowed scientists to predict with an
unprecedented precision the way in which
an electron reacts to a magnetic field
through virtual photons the magnetic
field causes the spin of the electron to
process
and this precession motion is perfectly
predicted by quantum electrodynamics
to almost 10 significant figures
to this day all theories considered this
is the best verified experimental
prediction
in the history of physics the anomalous
magnetic moment
of the electron
[Music]
you